this is the most broken n ability in all
of Hunter Hunter Nan's wish granting his
power so dangerous that on a meta level
it comes shockingly close to Breaking
the actual story itself because once the
ability becomes known surely it becomes
the entire focus of this world because
we must control this power or there is
no greater threat to anything than this
power but it also comes with questions
such as why didn't kilo use wish
granting during the Chimera ant Arc it
would have been a pretty simple way to
get rid of this annoying ant king
problem or would it because the these
wishes aren't free unless you kill one
but even then they're not free and it's
purely for semantic reasons and if
you're a seasoned Honda Honda fan then I
know that nothing will excite you more
than the semantics of n abilities but I
also have something even better for you
because at the end of this video we are
going to calculate exactly what the cost
would be to make a wish to kill the ant
king marijam feel free to comment with
your BET right now and to be clear the
cost we're talking about is human lives
also this fictional Hunter content is
sponsored by uken fantastic little
robots that make charging your devices
fast and easy with 65 WS of high-speed
charging power you can charge an iPhone
15 to about 60% in just 30 minutes this
little bad boy right here is the ug
green NEX sod rg65 W charger and I know
this name very well because I genuinely
have three of these little friends
scattered throughout my office because I
am incredibly lazy and wherever I go I
want to make sure there's a thing that
can charge my stuff and this is the
thing they come equipped with
revolutionary G technology which
provides a whopping 95% energy
conversion efficiency and significantly
reduces heat generation whilst charging
in addition to ug Green's inbuilt
thermal guard protection to ensure the
safety of your devices here's the thing
though they look and are in fact wildly
adorable but don't let that fool you
because they pack an absolute punch when
it comes to power I often have one of my
dudes set up charging up to three
devices at once and it does so with an
assortment of cute Emoji Expressions
that change depending on the charge
status and ug green also has a 30 W
option should you desire lower power but
I really cannot recommend these guys
enough you can and should check them out
through my link in the description
because not only do they support the
life of my devices they also support the
life of this channel so do that thing
but for now it's back to you me before
we get into that though it's never been
confirmed that wish granting is a nen
ability however it was heavily implied
in chapter 334 when nanica grants the
wish of healing gone after which point a
colossal amount of what appears to be AA
was released no one specifically states
that it's a so maybe it's some sort of
unknown quantity of power but everything
else about it is consistent with the N
system particularly its adherence to
balance with one completely system
breaking exception every wish comes with
an equal and often exceptionally
horrifying consequence very in keeping
with the idea that or can only be used
to Grant great power at Great cost wish
granting is actually kind of like a
reverse Genie because to have a wish
granted you first need to fulfill three
of ala's requests so you grant three
wishes and then the genie appears nanuka
takes over ala's body and then nanica
will grant One Wish for You Alica could
say something like pick me up give me a
piggy back ride take my hand so that's
nice you do those three simple things
and then you get yourself a wish not a
bad day's work at all and because Siri
ala Yoshi hero Togashi loves game
mechanics ala demands work on a level
based system the three Al forementioned
demands are examples of level one
requests now let's say the person wishes
for a brand new car nice you got your
car and you just drive away like a boss
however the next person that aler
encounters will be given another set of
requests but this time let's say they're
level 10 requests because a new car had
a level 10 rating so instead of stuff
like pick me up and take my hand the
request is now something along the lines
of rip off your fingernails break your
arm cut off your foot something
something like that they what we're
going to call unreasonable requests and
if the person who came before you was
particularly greedy with their wish then
there's no telling just how high that
request level can go in fact there's a
certain point where Alica will reach
seemingly impossible requests such as
give me your liver give me your
intestines give me your spine or even
give me your brain those were actual
requests made after someone wished for a
a billion Jenny so slightly higher value
than a car 20 maybe even 30 times more
maybe even more more depending on the
car and this is a problem because if you
fail to meet these requests nanica then
kills you by squashing you into human
goop as well as kills the people closest
to you until enough lives have been
taken to justify the cost of the
previous wish however after this nanica
then resets to level one requests so
this this would be the prime time to
make a wish yourself also the same
person cannot make two wishes in a row
so this sort of prevents Nan's ability
from being repeated L abused by the same
person but also not really all that
happens is you just need at least two
people to abuse it instead and kilaa
himself suggests that the wishes nanica
can grant are probably Limitless
although I would say that there has to
be some limit because there's only so
much that exists to be paid as a cost in
this world/ Universe however that is so
far beyond our comprehension that it's
effectively Limitless but eventually you
will probably hit a point where the wish
granting ends up killing alaka herself
because at some point by virtue of
spending even a short amount of time
with the person she's making demands to
alaka herself will be somewhere on the
kill list very far down but if the wish
is big enough then nanuka could end up
eliminating alaka and thus maybe even
itself but this sort of thing is just
what happens when Dark Continent
creatures discover nen as soon as they
can access basic or control they
constitute a threat that could almost
instantly wipe out all of humanity it
happened with the Chimera ants and it
happened here again with nanika AKA The
Dark Continent Calamity eye and like a
lot of n abilities wish granting also
comes with a secret condition known only
to the user and or a specific Target of
the user in this case kilawa because
whilst everyone else is granted a wish
kiloa and only kilaa has the ability to
issue nanika with a command and because
a command is semantically different from
a wish kilawa is able to bypass any
backlash from previous wishes and also
kila's command will be enacted without
repercussions from the wish system
wishes and commands exist in two
completely different systems a wish does
not affect a command nor does a command
affect a wish or its requirements and
given that they exist separate from each
other kilawa can even make commands
whilst nanuka is in the middle of making
her own requests but essentially kilawa
has Limitless power at his disposal all
he needs to do is ask so kilawa could
have simply wished to kill the ant king
and then bam maram would have been gone
without any consequences at all which
Chad is not particularly balanced
although in terms of you know the nens
the only real argument I can make for it
is that this power was granted to the
person least likely to use it the most
trustworthy because kilaa would never
want to use his sister like the rest of
his family hoped to other than that
though it's pretty completely broken so
question why didn't kway use nanika to
kill or otherwise defeat maram and also
secondary question why didn't kilway use
nanuka to heal kite and by heal I mean
bring back to life because both gon and
kilwa thought that he was still
salvageable the easy answer to this is
because Togashi simply didn't know that
alakar existed yet which is actually my
answer to most hun Hunter questions
Tashi rarely thinks beyond the current
talk when he's writing however in this
particular case it's not that simple
because Togashi certainly did know that
alaka or someone who would eventually
become alaka already existed it's
slightly complicated and the Internet
isn't going to give you a
straightforward answer so here's what
and why there is a misconception that
ala was planned from the early days of
Hunter Hunter because in the 2011 anime
they show a silhouette of the whole zic
family which includes ala and for people
who haven't read the Manga it seems like
alaka had been planned from the very
beginning and look in that particular
version of Hunter Hunter it's very solid
foreshadowing and also a case of just
plain literal shadowing because manga
authors love their Silhouettes but
there's also a sub misconception of
people being a bit perplexed by the
silhouette people thinking that the
anime showed alaka before the manga did
because it's a common belief that the
2011 anime didn't even know if they were
going to tackle the Chimera an talk
because it hadn't finished when the
anime started airing which is one
explanation for why kite story in
chapter 1 was booted and therefore if
the Chimera antar hadn't finished being
published in the manga then how could
the anime show ala who did not exist yet
in this silhouette well the reason for
this is because none of that's true the
2011 anime started airing on October 2nd
2011 and the very next day on October
3rd the final Chimera antar chapter
final will was published the anime
production obviously started earlier
before the Chimera Anar ended but they
knew that they were going to be fine
they were practically at the Finish Line
already and later that very same month
and year Alo was first fully seen in the
manga and fun fact I'm actually writing
this video on the 2nd of October on the
12th anniversary of Hunter Hunter which
I was alerted to by this tweet whilst
literally writing this paragraph all of
which is to say that when it comes to
Hunter Hunter it can be much more
difficult to talk about than a lot of
other series because more so than most
fan bases I've encountered there's a
huge amount of urban myths that go on to
become truth because they're just
repeated so often I'm even guilty of
spreading a lot of them because I took
them at face value because people kept
saying them at me so I thought that they
must be true the people are saying it a
lot regardless in the manga aluka
silhouette does not appear we just hear
the word words of the zelic tour guide
who says the family presently consists
of five siblings the parents a set of
grandparents and a great-grandfather
assassins all so Togashi definitely knew
that there was another zelic he even
drew the character that would eventually
become alaka during the Chimera Anar in
chapter 229 one of my personal favorite
chapters because immediately after we
see this delightsome family photo fayan
calls Spinx a he may have and was
probably talking to zazan but I like to
think that it was in response to F's
offering to so in this case I don't
think it's fair to say that Togashi
didn't know that alakar existed yet I do
however think it's fair to say that he
hadn't fully baked this particular zic
cake because the real world time gap
between this photo and alica's proper
introduction was just under 7 years
unusually this is a scenario where I
think we should give Togashi credit
because the idea may have existed so
that means we return to the question of
why didn't Kow use alaka for anything
during the Chimera an talk and one
explanation is because the situation was
not as hopeless as election Aron's
condition was it's interesting to think
about but at the time nobody really knew
the full extent of maro's power the true
scale of the threat was not Quantified
until the mission was happening all the
extermination team really had to judge
things by was their brief experiences
with neito which gone and kilwa
genuinely thought that they could just
train hard and overcome Pito whilst Neto
handled the king I mean to be fair
you've got chairman Neto on your team
how could you lose Stakes were high but
I don't think anyone was truly prepared
for what they were going to encounter
except for netra whereas the situation
after gon's transformation was evidently
extremely dire because it was a
consequence of him needing to summon the
power to beat the creatures that we had
underestimated and now understood the
other and potentially also correct
explanation is because kilaa didn't want
to expose alaka to the world and this is
why kiloa is my favorite character in
Hunter Hunter because beyond all of the
cool action and comedy he's just a
genuinely nice guy who wanted to protect
his sister bringing aler in during the
Chimera ant events means exposing her to
the hunter Association and once they're
aware of her abilities aluka will be
hunted by someone whether it's the
association its individual Hunters the
Phantom troop the Khan Empire or the V5
Nations who were keeping track of Dark
Continent creatures whoever the power is
either too tempting to leave alone or
considered to be too dangerous to leave
alone even kilawa himself initially sees
nanuka as a threat and plans to make a
wish so that nanuka never wakes up again
and as it is to use nanuka during the
election Arc kilawa had to get a lot of
people on board to have it happen in
secrecy and the whole thing was very
much an internal zelic Family Affair
taking place on a very large scale
sometimes you'll even hear speculation
that ilam need was blocking kila's
memory of ala or at least it instilled
him with the idea that Letting alaka Go
free would be catastrophic and you know
what to that I say maybe but let's now
ask the ultimate question what would be
the cost of killing marijam to be clear
this is not a command this is a wish so
there will be a cost and the metric
we're going to use is the wish for a
billion Jenny Jenny of course being the
fictional currency that correlates
pretty much one to one with the Japanese
Yen and the exchange rate of a billion
yen is approximately 6 million
129 so to make that wish a reality cost
the lives of 67 people the poor zelic
servant yasua her lover and 65 other
people that were closest to her as in
spent the most time with her over her
life not close as in proximity which is
an important distinction in fact the
zelic family are very lucky that they
adopt an antisocial policy with most
servants because this could have ended
up taking some of them out also they say
that it killed 67 people that we know of
implying that there could have been more
but we're going to stick to 67 which
means that according to nanuka a single
human life is worth approximately $9,600
so basically what we need to do from
here is figure out maro's net worth marm
is of course the ant dictator of escotto
meaning that he has complete control
over all of its resources and its 5
million inhabitants now eoro is not
particularly subtly based on North Korea
which has a gross domestic product of
around $8 billion US and as the dictator
of fictional North Korea we're going to
say that maroom is worth at least that
so if we divide that 18 billion by the
average worth of a human life the answer
we come to is that a wish to kill the
ant king maram would cost
18,720 lives which is honestly a lot
less than I thought it would be however
this is a conservative estimate because
maro's value can't necessarily be
Quantified by net worth alone it may Al
take his strength into account maybe
there's even a cper or a system involved
or maybe it even takes his potential
future into account but with that in
mind I think the hunter Association got
a bit of a bargain taking marow wham's
life at the cost of one chairman it was
either that or at least 180,000 humans
or in the worst case all of humanity
however if it was a command then none of
that matters because command granting is
the single most broken ability in Hunter
Hunter